it's been almost 150 years since Queen
Victoria opened Royal Albert Hall in
honor of her beloved late husband Prince
Albert
since then the London concert venue has
seen decades of world-class performances
but not with world-class sound now
that's changed and in a big way with
installation of what's said to be the
world's largest single room speaker
system mt st i've got a look and perhaps
more importantly listen for plenty of
folks he needs no introduction for this
2006 performance which saw jay-z come
out of supposted retirement was the
Royal Albert Hall eyes first
introduction to hip hop a history-making
headlining act at a London landmark that
first opened its doors in 1871 it's one
of Britain's most distinctive
performance venues the Royal Architects
at the time didn't take acoustics into
account when they built that majestic
dome ceiling and from the very beginning
the venue suffered from an ear rattling
performance echo I'm sure he's now
improve wholly Jeffrey is the chief
technician at the Royal Albert Hall you
tear it four or five times from
different places and actually if you
paid to hear it you don't hear it five
times
but the world's biggest axe kept coming
the advent of amplified sound brought
electrifying acts like the Jimi Hendrix
Experience
[Music]
and Led Zeppelin while this recording of
Adele's 2011 performance became a
best-seller
[Music]
who are some of the biggest acts we've
seen on the stage oh gosh the variety is
Adele The Beatles Rolling Stones this is
the review and this is a view and it's
pretty stunning view when you stand here
looking out from a performance
perspective it's it's amazing I mean
it's almost as beautiful as looking this
way
the last major fix of the sound system
was back in 1969 when these giant discs
or mushrooms as they're called were
attached to the ceiling and they are
made of fiberglass and and the design of
those in essence is that the sound goes
up and then it comes back down but it's
much more controlled in how that works
the now iconic mushrooms helped but that
echo was still there so in 2017 the
green light was given for the biggest
ever overhaul of the acoustics so now it
wasn't very well all with engineers
working overnight 50,000 feet of new
cables 465 new speakers and 2.7 million
dollars the world's biggest single room
sound system has been installed
[Music]
[Music]
right it's like literally just lifted
the sound up from the ground that's
exactly what we wanted to do a fix 150
years in the making for a beloved venue
it provides something so unique that
intimacy there the look of the baton is
actually beautiful that now sounds as
beautiful as it looks
proceed yes this morning Saturday and
feel shy of Monday yeah exactly it is
one of the most beautiful rooms to be in
for a performance it's nice that the
sound finally matter how beautiful it is